Rachel's with us Rachel's in Birmingham
hi Rachel welcome that I have Ramsey
show hi thank you for taking my call
sure my question is that I'm this I'm in
my second marriage and my husband I just
started taking the Financial Peace
University and we've got our budget
together and doing really well but
decided to try to put our checking
account together we came in with one I
came in with one but we're we can't get
on the same page about it well just
wanted your thoughts I think he wants
security and knowing that he has it on
account
I like transparency so I think having a
joint account where we have access and
can visualize what's coming in and going
out is important yeah so I just I wanted
your opinion on it well I feel very very
strongly after 30 years of doing this
that combined accounts are the only way
to win with money are the highest
probability of winning with money it's
not the only way but it's the highest
probability and the reason is all the
data points tell us that a high-quality
marriage is one of the recurring
statistical themes in people who build
wealth a high quality marriages people
who trust each other and people who have
high levels of transparency and high
levels of communication and relationship
has grown in that situation both of you
coming into this from second marriage
know you said you were both of you from
second marriage so you carry baggage in
and he's it's a he it's human nature to
take the crap of the ex-wife and paint
you with that brush and it's human
nature for you to take the crap by the
ex-husband and paint him with that brush
but we cannot look backward and deal
from our wounds we have to look forward
and say what is a proper healthy process
that takes us past our wounds and causes
us to never be in the place we were with
those other marriages and so you're on
the right track
if I'm you I'm gonna gently but firmly
force that issue because independence is
something you want if you're not married
but once you get married the preacher
says and now you are one unto thee all
my worldly goods I pledge the old
marriage vows say hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]